une allure patrimoine dern mais un
décollage impeccable les stars du
week-end ont fait leur show à l'aéroport
de toussus le noble
certains de ses avions de la seconde
guerre mondiale ont été pilotées par le
régime en normandie niemen qui a
stationné dans la commune en 1946 1947
l'association aerea story voulait faire
connaître cette histoire aux yvelinois
ce sont des gens qui étaient courageux
qui était qu'ils avaient de l'abnégation
qui était prêt à tout pour défendre leur
pays
il y en a beaucoup qui sont morts ce
sont devenus des héros et il faut que
les jeunes ne sachent il faut faire
passer ses valeurs c'est un petit peu ça
notre objectif
passionné d'aviation d'histoire ou juste
curieux
les familles étaient nombreuses à faire
le déplacement c'était l'occasion voilà
deux d'avoir du concret de voir ses
avions de près on a eu la chance de les
voir décoller se mettre en route
et puis on a eu des conférences surtout
très intéressante et aujourd'hui et hier
un biplan de conception des années 30 un
yack capable de voler à 600 kilomètres
heure et un mustang américains pouvant
atteindre les 700 km heure des avions
historiques qui ont émerveillé petits et
grands c'est la première fois que j'en
vois au vrai et béthune je vends d'ecia
dessin animé j'ai pensé qu'à ça
développement il se développe mais notre
culture générale et elle devenait
meilleur intéressé de voir ça intéressés
par l'histoire de normandie niemen de l'
aventure un peu d des pilotes de cette
partie de l'histoire
le régiment de chasse normandie niemen
est toujours opérationnel sur tous les
fronts la france est présente avec des
avions plus récents les rafales